Щоразу грають так, ніби востаннє.
Адже чи відбудеться наступна вистава - тут, в Одеському українському театрі імені Василя Василька -
точно ніхто не знає. Нині близько третини творчого складу - на фронті.
Рік воював на Херсонському та Запорізькому напрямках і … знову опинився в стінах рідного театру.
Роман Федосєєв вступив до лав ЗСУ в перші дні нападу Росії на Україну.
Спочатку служив гранатометником, а згодом став старшим бойовим медиком роти.
Пережив поранення й контузії, а після них - тривале лікування.
І ось тепер Роман готується до повернення на сцену.
Мене звільнили в запас і я повернувся в рідний театр.
Тому що це моя професія.
Моя професія - актор та режисер,
а військовий я був тоді, коли був у ЗСУ.
І зараз мене вводять на одну виставу "Карпатський вестерн".
Я буду грати Василя.
Це одна з провідних ролей цієї вистави.
Багато тексту, багато рухів.
Із головною роллю впоратися буде нелегко,
адже нині Роман відновлюється після поранень і контузій.
Так, у мене є декілька, на жаль, поранень.
У мене там з коліном і дві дуже такі сильні контузії.
Я лежав в шпиталі, зараз лікуюсь, реабілітація і втратив багато слуху.
Ну, я так не дуже гарно чую все.
Заважає вам це зараз працювати чи ні?
Звичайно, заважає. Кожна болячка заважає.
Тим більше, де я побував. Я на це не скаржуся.
Там хлопцям ще гірше дісталось і зараз дістається.
Це все, що тут відбувається, завдяки нашим побратимам, які зараз боронять нашу державу.
Поверненню в театр Роман неабияк зрадів,
бо сцену вважає найкращими ліками.
Утім, не менше зраділи й в самому театрі, адже через брак акторів-чоловіків
уже довелося скасувати не одну виставу.
А тутешні реалії такі: чим довше спектакль не грають -
тим складніше його згодом повернути в репертуар.
Останні півтора місяці були дуже складні.
Забрали нашого актора й полетів майже весь репертуар.
Є вистави, які ми більше ніколи не зіграємо.
Наприклад, чудова вистава "Сорочинський ярмарок"...
Минуло забагато часу, купа людей змінилася.
Робити вводи до цієї вистави - це шалений час.
Ще декілька вистав загублені, й ми не зможемо до них повернутися.
Наприклад, ми не повернемося до частини тих вистав, які були до війни.
"Золоте теля" ми не зможемо зіграти,
тому що ту кількість людей, яка пішла з театру, замінити просто неможливо.
І коли третину творчого складу мобілізовано,
то під загрозою не лише окремі вистави, а й робота самого театру.
Тож Юлія Пивоварова намагається домогтися бронювання для військовозобов'язаних працівників.
Мова не йде про те, що актори не мають воювати.
Автори мають воювати. Ми всі з вами розуміємо, що найголовніше зараз - війна.
Але нам треба розуміти, що є необхідність в збереженні українського театру в Одесі.
Мова йде про те, що це має бути якимось чином врегульовано.
Ми маємо якимось чином планувати те, що ми робимо.
Що має бути хоча б невелика кількість заброньованих і акторів,
і монтувальників, і освітлювачів, і звукорежисерів.
З початку повномасштабного вторгнення Росії
бронювання для акторів отримали лише театри,
які мають статус національних. Їх в Україні лише вісім.
А всі інші стикнулися з проблемою мобілізації.
Утім, саме в Одесі мобілізація "театралів" набрала таких обертів,
що під загрозою опинилося існування цілого театру.
Загалом в регіоні неодноразово фіксували резонансні випадки вручення повісток.
Дісталося й працівникам театру імені Василька, розповідає директорка.
За її словами, заслуженого актора України Павла Чирву забрали до військкомату просто з вулиці.
Він йшов роздрукувати слова, йшов на репетицію.
Біля "Нового ринку" до нього підійшли, заштовхали в бус.
У людини не було з собою ані грошей, ані жодного документа.
Його заштовхали, він встиг зателефонувати головному режисеру нашого театру,
до якого він йшов на репетицію:
"Вибач, я на репетицію не прийду, тому що мене везуть у військкомат".
Далі з ним зник зв'язок. Далі я по своїх каналах шукала, де він знаходиться.
Ввечері його вивезли за місто. Ніякої медичної комісії взагалі не було.
Це відбувалося взагалі в неділю. Як це може бути?
Відтоді актор Павло Чирва на фронті.
Крім нього, на різних напрямках боронять Україну ще шістнадцять працівників театру.
Близько половини з них мобілізувалися добровільно.
Ми чекаємо на пацанів. Вони повернуться, ми будемо працювати далі.
Але на той момент, коли вони вступили до війська, це був удар для театру.
Попри проблеми з кадрами та регулярні ракетні удари РФ по Одесі,
театр продовжує творити й працювати.
Крім того, каже головний режисер, одесити почали частіше відвідувати вистави.
І цьому дуже тішаться в театрі, який багато років поспіль залишався в тіні російськомовних театрів міста.
Коли в нас було "не все так однозначно"
і ми були в досить дружніх стосунках з тварюками, які на нас напали,
навіть в той момент ми грали українською
і ніколи не переходили на російську мову.
І відповідно це був такий осередок української культури.
У нас були гастролі, ми їздили в область.
Ми возили класичні українські вистави.
Їх дивилось і молдавське село, і гагаузьке село.
Що це, як не робота з українізації російськомовного регіону?
І тепер головне завдання колективу - зберегти театр.
Тож уже понад пів року директорка оббиває пороги усіх можливих інстанцій,
аби домогтися бронювання для військовозобов'язаних працівників.
Ми зверталися і до Міністерства культури,
ми зверталися до Генерального штабу,
ми зверталися до Міністерства оборони,
тому що ми розуміємо, що на місцевому рівні вирішити це питання неможливо.
Просто неможливо. Або ти йдеш "домовляєшся"... Але це неправильно.
Якщо ми живемо в нормальній країні, то це все має відбуватися за законом.
Втім, у Міністерстві культури на запит DW відповіли:
займаються тільки питаннями закладів культури, які носять статус національних,
а Одеський український театр імені Василька такого статусу не має.
Тож нині доля акторів театру в руках Генерального штабу.
13 жовтня Юлія Пивоварова надіслала усі необхідні документи до Генштабу, вони й досі на розгляді.
Втім, у театрі кажуть: яким би не було рішення, стати на захист України готові,
але просять про єдине - збереження театру.
Мені нестрашно вступити до війська,
але мені страшно, що мені не буде куди повернутися.
Бахмута вже немає, повернутися додому я вже не зможу.
Мені як людині, яка дуже любить цей театр,
мені дуже важко уявити, що мені потім не буде куди повернутися.
Актор для цього театру - сенс існування.
Якщо забираєш сенс існування - людина може померти.
Якщо забрати сенс існування в театру, актора, - він загине. Його не буде.